today on the matt walsh show mega
corporations are now condemning and
boycotting the state of georgia as
punishment for a law that protects the
integrity and safety of elections in
that state
this is just the latest example of the
wealthiest and most powerful
institutions
acting on the left's behalf even as
leftists pretend to be
the counterculture resistance we'll talk
about that also five headlines including
an attack on capitol police officers
that is already being
memory hold for obvious reasons arkansas
moves to
ban the genital mutilation of children
and a pastor in canada shows us how to
deal
with agents of the state who infringe on
our rights and finally in our daily
cancellation speaking of agents of the
states
infringing on our rights uh the cdc has
given me yet another example
or another reason to cancel them so
we'll do that talk about all that and
much more today on the matte wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
this is something we'll be talking about
today plenty so it's uh it's good that
it comes up now
um you know charity mobile i've been
telling you about them for for
months now and they're one of my
favorite sponsors on the show they're
the pro-life phone company they are a
company a corporation
that is actually on our side in the
culture and when we have companies like
that
it's not it's not only about not
supporting the companies that hate us
it's also about supporting the companies
that are on our side charity mobile is
one of those five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice
now we know the right to life is the key
that unlocks other rights now through
april 16th
if you if you take advantage of this and
you become a
customer of charity mobile new
activations get a free cell phone after
instant credit plus free activation free
shipping and a free pro-life key chain
you get all of that
uh there's no co no contracts no
termination fees and no risk with a
30-day guarantee
what that means is you might as well try
it out you might as well become a
customer if you don't like it i think
you will but if you don't
you're not locked in they've got live
customer service also based right here
in the usa
which is really important too getting
those usa jobs on top of it so if you
want to become a charity mobile customer
like i am
call them at 1-877-474-3662
or you can chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
it was announced late last week that
major league baseball would be
moving the all-star game and the draft
out of atlanta in protest of georgia's
new law meant to
ensure safe and free elections in the
state the league commissioner explained
the move saying quote
i've decided that the best way to
demonstrate our values as a sport is by
relocating this year's all-star game and
mlb draft
major league baseball fundamentally
supports voting rights for all americans
and opposes restrictions to the ballot
box
now this move will cost georgia 100
million dollars
when i say cost georgia 100 million
dollars i mean
cost its people the citizens 100 million
dollars
kemp the governor isn't going to feel
any personal financial impact neither
will any of the
state legislatures legislators probably
who voted for the bill
all of the pain will be felt by the
people who
own or work in the restaurants hotels
retail outlets and so on
around where the game was to be held and
you could imagine that these
establishments
had been relying on and looking forward
to um
having the all-star game so they can
start recouping a lot of the losses that
they suffered over the past year
they're the ones who are going to lose
money and will suffer the pain
this raises the question why punish
working people for the alleged
sins of political leaders well you might
be able to answer that question
when you consider why blm militants
would burn down a local convenience
store
for the alleged sins of the police it's
the same kind of strategy
there are other questions more pertinent
questions to be asked um like
why does major league baseball have
values as a sport
and what does that mean exactly and if a
sport can
have values why would its values have
anything to do with the election law in
georgia
why does baseball have an opinion on
georgia election law
and if quote major league baseball
fundamentally supports voting rights for
alden why do they have a problem with
the georgia law
despite the propaganda from the democrat
party and its media mouthpieces
the georgia law will not prevent a
single person from voting i'll say it
again
the georgia law will not prevent a
single person from voting
rather it puts in place let me i guess i
should clarify it will not prevent a
single
legal voter from voting it rather puts
in place some very minimal restrictions
and requirements
to ensure election integrity including
some new id requirements for absentee
voting
it doesn't ban minorities from voting or
in any way interfere with anyone's
ability to vote
it doesn't make voting hard or confusing
for anyone but the most incompetent and
befuddled and if those sorts of people
don't end up voting well no loss there
i saw for example somebody on twitter
complaining and
this i'm not making this up complaining
that the id
requirement for absentee voting may be
confusing for people because
they might not know where to find their
driver's license number on their
driver's license
and they're going to need that in order
to submit their id for absentee voting
that's very confident where do you find
the driver's license number on your
driver's license
well you know if you can't crack the
code of your driver's license
and can't be bothered to google the
question and solve your confusion that
way
then we're definitely better off without
your input
if if that stops you from voting then i
am
very glad that you have been stopped
from voting because you are so
stupid that you have really no business
voting or or
or acting in society as an adult at all
i mean i'm worried about the fact that
you're that you drive a car
i'm worried about all the other things
you're doing if you're that dumb
but other than the sort of fantastic
idiots who cannot decipher his own photo
id
everyone else will still be able to vote
in georgia without a problem
that we're also going to leave aside for
a moment the much remarked upon fact
that the people
protesting the id requirements for
voting are the same people almost to a
man the same people
who want vaccine passport requirements
for everything else in life so you can't
it's it's we don't want to have a an id
of to vote
once every two years if that um
but a vaccine passport to do
everything else every day that's fine
that's not onerous
in fact putting that and everything
already mentioned to the side
the question i'd really like to focus on
today is this
how can the people who have major
corporations
like mlb taking their side still
consider themselves to be
radicals and rebels members of the
cultural
resistance mlb is not the only company
to
publicly take the left side on the issue
coca-cola
a company which as fox news points out
an article on its site
still requires id to attend its
shareholder meetings
they issued a statement condemning those
same sort of requirements for voting it
said quote
voting is a foundational right in
america and we have long championed
efforts to make it easier to vote we
want to be crystal clear and state
unambiguously that we are disappointed
in the outcome of the georgia voting
legislation
well coca-cola is disappointed
if that doesn't change your mind i don't
know what will delta
um also joined the corporate outrage
brigade along with apple
microsoft google citibank and many
others
of course most of the major media
outlets are part of this crew cbs
published a news article
big air quotes around news there pushing
more companies to help quote
fight georgia's restrictive new voting
law that's a news article
but the most effective thing that these
outlets can do
in the media as noted is simply lie
about what's in the bill and they've
been doing that with reckless abandon
ever since
it was signed once again with the voter
id issue
as with nearly every other issue you can
name to include especially race and lgbt
issues
the left has on its side as dedicated
advocates first cause
all of the biggest and most powerful
corporations in the world to go along
with the media academia hollywood the
government
whatever else this means it certainly
means that if you are on the left
you are not a counterculture warrior
seeking to tear down the system
you are the system you are the status
quo
you are the beneficiaries of all of the
systemic privilege
that society has to offer it all goes to
you
you are not oppressed every institution
with the power to oppress people is on
your side
and they oppress your opposition at your
behest
you are the privileged elite you are the
defenders of the rich and powerful
you are everything you claim to oppose
everything
you represent everything you hate now
you might say that i'm just a sore loser
here and maybe so
you know i i am i admit kind of sore
about the fact that we live in a culture
run by maniacs like yourselves i'm sorry
about that yes
but be that as it may the point remains
that you cannot have it both ways you
cannot
cosplay as a radical in your black
antifa ninja uniform
while also having citibank and microsoft
out there
doing your bidding i mean you can but
you're not gonna be taken seriously
if you do that what about the rest of us
what about those of us who actually
stand in opposition to the political and
cultural agenda of the richest and most
powerful people and institutions in the
world what about those of us who are
actual critics of the system those of us
who face
real systemic disadvantage and even
oppression
what should we do besides complain i
mean we got that covered i have that
covered so we're doing that
great what else can we do
one thing we can do is realize how
numerous
we still are now i don't buy the silent
majority
line i don't think we are in the
majority and if we are and we've been
silent then that's all the more
embarrassing for us i sort of hope
we're not in the majority if we're in
the majority we let all of this happen
and have been silent the whole time
you know it always it always confuses me
when conservatives say that proudly
we're
the silent majority well what are you
doing being silent you're cowards
that doesn't make me feel better
but even if we're not in the majority we
are still millions and millions strong
there's no doubt about that
there is power that comes with those
numbers
but we have to use the power we can't be
squeamish about it
and this should begin at the most basic
level
with refusing to give our money and
brand loyalty to companies that openly
hate us coca-cola
on the heels of telling its employees to
be less white
remember that is now openly fighting to
make our elections less safe and less
secure
we have to ask ourselves is their
product so important to our lives
so important that we're going to
continue to purchase it continue to
collectively put millions of dollars
into their coffers
even as they use the wealth and
influence we give them to work against
us and undermine us in the culture
is that 20 ounce coke you're drinking
with your lunch that crucial to you
would it be a major sacrifice to drink a
different brand or better yet
drink some water out of the tap
the answer is that it would be really no
sacrifice i mean you could cut
coke out of your life completely
and not feel the loss at all
except the weight loss maybe and if we
all did that
however many million of millions of us
if we all did that
which again we could all do that with no
effort
coke would be a major brand a billion
dollar transnational corporation
that would actually feel the consequence
of its own wokeness
it would feel it in a real way they
would lose millions of dollars
if not billions again we could make this
happen while virtually sacrificing
nothing and making no significant change
to our daily life
you could cut coke out of your life
without any effort your life would be
better for it in fact
coca-cola is a bad product that makes
you fat
unhealthy and ugly also the company that
sells it hates your guts
i mean how much more convincing do we
need
we we should never give them our money
again we we could
we could do the same with these other
companies and in most but not all cases
the sacrifice would be made with similar
ease
now some of these companies are so
ingrained in our lives that it would
require a little more effort than others
to extricate them
from our homes and our lifestyles still
it can be done
what's the argument for not doing it
i don't think there is one not a good
one anyway not anymore
there may have been a time when we
thought we could afford to take the high
road on boycotts and similar tactics i
myself was under that delusion for a
time
but no more we have
the power some power at least
not the kind of power the left has but
we still have some power
and it's high time that we start using
it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i want to take a second now to tell you
about our good friends over at rock auto
you know it's it's not a lot of fun to
waste time
at these auto parts stores when you
could be doing other things it's it's
even less fun
when it's spring out it's nice out and
you want to be doing other things with
your time so why do that why
walk aimlessly around the auto parts
store looking for what you're trying to
find you're probably not gonna find it
anyway if you do it's gonna be more
expensive than it should be
go to rockauto.com just pull your phone
out of your pocket
and go to rockauto.com they always offer
at the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on
what the market will bear you don't need
to spend up to twice as much for the
same parts makes no sense to do that
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
easy to navigate you can quickly see all
the parts available
for your vehicle and you could choose
the brand specifications and prices that
you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
so go to rockauto.com right now and see
all the parts available for your car
car or truck and remember as always to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about his box
so they know that we sent you well i
hope you had a blessed
and happy easter we had a you know a lot
of fun
in my house started with the start of
the day with a 6 a.m
easter egg hunt outside before church we
had to get it in before church and you
know
it wasn't going to work to hold the kids
off on the easter egg hunt until after
so we figured
uh we'd do it before so i apologize to
our neighbors for that
uh because we were outside doing an
easter egg hunt at like 6 a.m
fortunately my kids are you know they're
only about as loud as a busload of
coked up spider monkeys so it probably
wasn't
that much of a disturbance i have to say
though easter egg hunts have become
uh they've kind of gone downhill for me
in terms of how fun they are
ever since i got fired from the job of
filling the eggs
um before the east egg hunt so now i'm
the guy my job is to go hide them
but i don't get to fill them and the
reason i got fired from that job is a
few years ago
you know i had the idea to fill because
my wife
you know made the mistake of of giving
the job to me and she
like she she left me unattended and gave
gave me all the empty eggs and said yeah
fill these in
or do the easter egg hunt and so i
filled half of the eggs with things that
no kid
would ever want you know like olives
some of them just had rocks and grass
and stuff and then i also put
real raw eggs in some of the eggs
and i thought it would be hilarious and
it was um
until one of the kids opened one of the
eggs with an egg inside
and dropped it and it splattered all
over the place and got on his shoes and
everything
and then it was a big scene and my wife
gave me that look
that said you know you're you're banned
from doing this again but i still think
i believe the game
it lent the game some necessary
intensity when the eggs
contained both good and bad surprises
that's my feeling on now
you might there are there are those who
theorize
that filling the eggs is a tedious task
and so i did that on purpose so that i
would be banned from it forever in the
future and i would never have to do it
again
that's also a theory i'm not i'm not
gonna speculate on whether that's true
or not
okay uh number one moving on here from
the daily wire it says the deceased
assailant who rammed two u.s capitol
police officers friday and emerged from
his car wielding a knife
before before police shot him has been
identified as a 25 year old
african-american man from indiana
who believed louis farrakhan is an
incarnation of jesus christ
nbc's pete williams reported friday that
capitol police identified the suspect as
a 25 year old man from indiana
uh who may have lived in virginia on his
facebook page he notes that he's a
follower of the nation of islam
according to msnbc's jesse rodriguez
and he's now dead now that facebook page
apparently was deleted
like within seconds so some
enterprising journalists and by that i
don't mean mainstream
media journalists but some other
journalists on on twitter went to
facebook and and pulled a lot of this
stuff
and posted it before facebook took it
down
and they it's it's creepy how fast
facebook acted
to take the page down and why take the
page down at all i mean i know why they
did it i know the real reason why they
did it
but um what would even be the stated
reason
yeah the guy did a horrible thing so now
we now we take the page down
why i mean
it it might tell us it tells us
something about his motives why he did
it this is this is all pertinent
information
and of course again that but that's
that's why they take the page downs
because they don't want us to know
and uh that happened what was that that
happened on
friday and here we are on monday only a
few days later
and uh already of course the media has
moved on
and we don't have to get into you know
we could start i could start pulling the
tweets and everything from
from people on the left who when we
heard about the attack there was
something going on at the capitol and
we knew that at least one police officer
had been hurt or killed and of course
they were speculating
immediately it's just stating that it
might it must be a white male that
wasn't the case at all
um we don't have to get into that we
know that's the way it goes
but already right down the memory hole
we know that's the way it goes to the
the culprit is
is not who they need it to be
politically and we move on very quickly
know that that mass shooting by the
syrian immigrant
that was that 10 people were killed
we stopped talking about that it's like
never happened
that's the power the media has to move
the conversation as i suppose they would
put it
um number two arkansas passed a bill
banning the genital mutilation of
children and i believe that uh well the
bill was
passed by the arkansas senate hasn't
been signed by the governor yet i
believe
but the daily wire reports the arkansas
said it passed the
arkansas save adolescence from the
experimentation act
or safe act on monday now it heads to
republican governor asa hutchinson's
desk for him to sign into law
the state government has a compelling
interest in protecting the health and
safety of its citizens especially
vulnerable children house bill 1570 says
uh let's go to what the bill bans here's
the list
uh the bill bans a physician or other
healthcare professional from providing
gender transition procedures to any
individual under 18 years of age
okay a physician or other healthcare
professional from referring any
individual
under 18 years of age to any healthcare
professional for gender transition
procedures
it also bans public funds from being
directly or indirectly used
granted paid or distributed to any
entity organization or individual
that provides gender transition
procedures to any individual under 18
years of age
there's a little more to it than that
but that's that's the basic thing there
it is specifically about protecting kids
under 18
miners from
having these things done to them that
cannot be fully reversed
and that they cannot consent to
because they're minors and supposedly
we all agree in in most other contexts
that minors cannot consent
they don't have the full capacity
consent because they don't
their brains are not fully developed yet
their brains will not be fully developed
especially the parts of their brain
that are involved in discernment
involved in long-term thinking and
planning
those parts of their brain won't be
fully developed until 25 so they're far
away from that
which which means it's incoherent to say
oh well we want to do this procedure
on this 16 year old because they this is
what they want
and it's best for them that's incoherent
they don't really know what they want
and they have no idea what's best for
them
they can't choose it
in effect if you are
doing a a procedure you know to use the
euphemistic phrase if you're doing a
procedure if you are mutilating the
genitals of a 16 year old
you are doing it against their will
period
because they cannot choose it
it's the same thing we would say if
there was a sixth if there was a
uh you know a 40 year old man
having sex with a 16 year old child
we would say that was against that
child's will
even if they verbally consent it it's
against their will because they ca
they cannot actually consent they cannot
psychologically consent to this
that's really the way to phrase this
this this bans
doctors from performing these procedures
on people against their will
and if they're doing it to kids against
their will
now msnbc and the rest of the media
responded to this about the way you'd
expect
but i thought this segment was it almost
managed to stand out for how
incredibly dishonest and misleading it
was let's let's listen
arkansas governor asa hutchison has
already signed a law banning women and
girls from competing on sports teams
consistent with their gender identity
now the state legislature has sent
another
anti-trans bill to his desk one that
would ban minors from receiving gender
affirming health care
unfortunately arkansas is not an outlier
according to the aclu's latest account
legislators in more than half the states
have introduced or passed
some type of anti-trans legislation what
is motivating this
other than hate yes jonathan we are
seeing a
terrible wave of anti-transgender bills
across the country
and you know this is nothing new for the
lgbtq community
over the years we have seen all
different types and ways of trying to
exclude
lgbtq people from daily life but these
attacks are particularly
egregious we're seeing attacks on young
people on their ability to participate
in school in school sports
and we're seeing attacks on the ability
to access life-saving gender affirming
health care
and so the nastiness and the in the
message from all of these
is we do not want you here we do not
want trans youth in our schools
we do not include you and we we wish to
keep you out
of our daily life so terrible
aclu trans justice campaign strategist i
cannot think of a more useless
collection of
of words is there a more useless title
than that
the whole thing is is what they're
talking about again what they're
defending here
is the genital mutilation of children
and and the um
the chemical castration of children
because those are kinds of drugs that
they're using on these kids
chemically castrating them these are
bills that ban the chemical castration
of children
and what you have there are you know
leftists on a major media
outlet openly defending it
defending it here's the thing defending
it not as
uh they're they're not approaching this
as though they're defending a very
controversial
stance okay uh they're defining it like
this is obvious
how could anyone how could anyone be
against chemically castrating a 14 year
old boy
this is unbelievable this is absurd
the only reason that you could be
against it is hate
well yeah you're right actually you're
you're right about that i am against it
for hate
i hate the idea of doing that to a kid
i do personally i
really hate the idea of chemically
castrating kids
of of generally mutilating them i hate
that idea
so you're right
but notice that the euphemism again now
it's um
and it keeps it keeps changing once upon
a time we used to call this
a sex change surgery and even that
so it's it's it's euphemism on top of
euphemism on top of euphemism
even the term sex change surgery
was ridiculous because you you cannot
actually do that
okay you you mutilate a man's penis you
have not
changed his sex at all you haven't even
come close to doing it
you can't do it it'll never happen
but that at least there you had the word
change
and surgery okay so that it was the the
sex part
sex change that's where the the
euphemism and that's how it became
misleading
but at least you had change and surgery
so you knew that okay this is surgery
it's something
a little more serious surgery is a
serious thing and we're changing
something
we're making a change
but the left can't that even that little
bit of honesty
they cannot allow and so we went from
uh sex change surgery to gender
reassignment
surgery which now we're now we're going
way into the weeds of delusion here
growing sex now it's gender doesn't make
any sense because they say that gender
okay the gender has nothing to do with
sex
a guy with a penis can still be a woman
in terms of his gender and
so so why what do you mean you're if
gender is a social construct
how can you reassign it through surgery
if gender has nothing to do with your
body
how can you reassign someone's gender
with surgery it doesn't make any sense
of course nothing these p these these
maniacs say makes any sense
um so it was so this was
sex change surgery gender reassignment
surgery
um and now even more of a euphemism
because we got gender reassignment oh
we're just reassigning
as if it was a sign to begin with
because that's what the doctors do right
they just a sign all they do is they
look at the baby and they come up with
with a label like slapping a sticker on
it assigning it
um but then that's even that was
too too honest and so now we're at uh
gender affirmation healthcare
we're not changing it's uh we're not
changing anything we're just
we're affirming by chemically castrating
a 14 year old we're we're affirming
something affirming him in his confusion
i suppose so yeah and it's healthcare
i mean you're using the healthcare now
you're using these drugs off label these
drugs were not
made or developed to be used by
physically healthy
kids
euphemism on top of euphemism on top of
euphysm that's and that's how they get
away with this
that's how they change you know they
change public perception
and it's quite brilliant it's quite evil
quite twisted but it's quite brilliant
on top of it
they're cut they're they're they never
constantly changing the language
they never let they can never let it be
because once people start to realize and
they get wise to the game
then the left says okay we got to change
the language again
they're innovators it's a process of
innovation
now it's innovation um
for in order to deceive
it's innovation for the sake of
deception but it is its innovation
all right let's move on number three a
pastor in canada
had the cop show up to his church and
um this happened uh on good friday i
believe
and i think he he gave us a this is how
you deal with it
okay this right here i think is how you
deal with the police showing up at his
church without a warrant trying to shut
him down
and here's how he handled the problem
let's listen
please get out get out of this property
immediately get out
get out of this property immediately
i don't want to hear anything out of
this property immediately i don't wanna
hear the word
out out out of this property
immediately until you come back with the
warrant out
ouch
immediately out immediately
go out and don't come back don't i don't
want to talk to you
[Music]
immediately out i don't care what you
have to say
out out out of this property or nazis
out
is not allowed here immediately gestapo
is not
all right so there you go i like how
uh i just like i was not letting the
this this lady get a there's some
bureaucrat there along with the police
and she's trying to give her line about
you know we'll say whatever
we can't even hear what you're saying
he's he's not gonna he's not gonna have
the conversation
with with her he's saying just get the
hell out we're not talking about this
i'm not i'm not gonna explain to you why
i have the right
in my church to to uh to worship
you know with with my flock i'm not
gonna explain it to you we're not gonna
when not gonna discuss it
i'm not gonna debate it with you you
just need to get the hell out and so
he's screaming at her and i love that
happy easter to that pastor we need
about a million more of him
that's what we need if we had a million
more of that guy we'd be in good shape a
million more of those that guy
running churches and uh
and uh you know christian communities
across across the
the world is exactly how to do it
now normally you know throw in nazi and
gestapo out there
normally i'm not a fan of that but
all the the his idea here is just to
keep contempt
on on these people and that i'm fine
with
because that's what you have to do
and if you're a police officer
and you're sent to go shut down a church
you know and and you follow that order
then you deserve the contempt
you deserve that treatment 100 percent
i i think history has taught us and yes
the nazis did also teach us this as well
that uh i'm following if i'm following
orders
is not an excuse it's not a
moral justification we learned that from
the nazis and from many other historical
examples
so you you follow that order i i know i
get it's difficult
you could lose your job who knows what
else could happen
but when you're told by your superiors
yeah we need you to go shut down this
church on good friday
your answer should be hell no not going
to happen
okay not really related but on the
subject of easter
and pastors we go from good to evil here
because i want
i did have to mention this senator
warnock of
georgia a fake christian fake pastor so
we got a good
good pastor there looking out for his
flock here we have a fake one
and someone trying to lead his flock
astray
and here's what he tweeted and he
deleted this which is interesting
but he tweeted uh the meaning of easter
is more transcendent than the
resurrection of jesus christ
we could really just stop it right there
the meaning of easter is more
transcendent than the resurrection of
jesus christ
more transcendent not even the meaning
of easter
is is is something other than it's more
transcendent then
uh then he continues whether you're
christian or not
through a commitment to helping others
we are able to save ourselves
my god and this is a
christian christian pastor he has his
own church
uh the meaning of easter is more
transcended than the resurrection of
jesus christ i think i don't have to
explain right
i don't think i have to explain why this
is heresy
and not not heresy you're not calling it
heresy in some sort of colloquial way
because i
no it's this is actual heresy this is
what heresy sounds like
in fact the meaning of easter is only
the resurrection of jesus christ that's
that's all it is that's
everything it is it doesn't need to be
more than that that's it that's
everything
but but even the the so you have heresy
here which is
really the main problem
but also on top of the heresy you have
this
dull kind of nothing
sort of message
is it what he's saying what is to him
what is more
transcendent than jesus christ
rising from the grave the tomb is empty
rising we have christ rising from the
grave to redeem mankind
would seem to me to be the the most
transcendent
thing ever in the history of reality
what does he say is more transcended
than that um
helping others a commitment to helping
others
this dry hr manager type
lingo is what he wants to replace
the resurrection of jesus with
what does that even mean whether you're
christ christian or not through a
commitment to helping others we're able
to save ourselves
again leaving aside the heresy of it if
we can do that
what does that mean helping others
what so you're not helping your flock
when you spew heresy at them number one
and number two
when you say something like well we
should help others okay
yes everyone i don't think anyone is
against helping
in principle there's no anti-help
helping
faction out there but it really depends
on
what are we helping people do and how
are we helping them do it
that's what we need to know
i would think that
as christians we should be helping
others
live holy and godly lives as best we can
that's the sort of help we should be
giving people of course we can't do that
for them
we can't save them we can't redeem them
but we can help
people as best as we can
you know thomas aquinas said loving to
love someone is to will the good of the
other and so
um to the extent that we can we can will
the good
of others we can help them on the path
to holiness
just as we would hope that they would do
for us
yeah that's a worthwhile message not
when you package it with heresy but but
it's a worthwhile message
a fine message for easter but that's not
of course what raphael
warnock is saying he doesn't mean help
others
in in holiness
what he means is um and when he says
helping really the people doing the
helping would be the government but
people like him he's a senator
and that's that's what he so helping is
is through
things like policy and law and that's
how you create a
utopia on earth
is by ceding all of your power to these
government officials who will then
point you in the right direction by
compelling you there and by
creating a policy that will that will
you know uh
instate a utopia and that's that's
that's his theology
which is not at all a christian theology
in the slightest bit
okay number five this is from the bbc
says amazon has apologized to a u.s
politician for falsely denying that
drivers are at times
forced to urinate in plastic bottles
mark pokan a democrat from wisconsin
referenced amazon making quote workers
urinate in water bottles in a tweet
the official amazon twitter account then
replied if that were true nobody would
work for us
the company has now apologized after
evidence emerged of drivers having to
urinate in bottles
uh amazon said a statement we owe an
apology to representative pocan
the tweet was incorrect it did not
contemplate our larger driver population
and instead wrongly focused only on our
fulfillment centers
um it added that fulfillment centers all
have dozens of toilets that employees
can use at any time
okay i i i do not have the
i have no interest really in defending
amazon here at all that's that's not
a job that i'm gonna take on for myself
but i i will say it i don't quite
understand
how it's amazon's fault if a driver has
to urinate in a bottle
which can i say who among us who among
us has not
had to come up with creative urination
solutions while on long road trips who
among us
but any case what what is amazon
supposed to do they've got drivers
they've got to drive across the country
are they themselves supposed to build
you know rest stops every every three
miles everywhere in the country
and if you're a man peeing in a bottle
which i would assume you'd
probably be a man if you're doing that
um that's that's that's really your own
fault because you what you can't find a
tree anywhere
if you're reduced to that i i don't see
how we can blame amazon for that that
that is the one little defense of amazon
i will give
okay moving on to reading the comments
this is from jackson brinton who says
matt i'm 16 and i still believe in the
easter bunny thank you for letting me
know he isn't real
well jackson plenty of 16 year olds
believe in dumber things in the easter
bunny so you're not too far
behind them uh another comment says the
concept of the easter bunny being six
feet tall is an entirely new concept to
me when i was a kid i was told he was
the size of an ordinary rabbit
wait a second what you thought the
easter bunny was the size of an ordinary
rabbit
how then how did you think
how was he bringing you the easter
basket what did he bring you did he
bring you anything
doesn't make any sense i always i guess
i i well that was my point
last week is that we we never had any
agreement on
who the easter bunny is or what he does
or anything and i guess i was never
specifically told that the easter bunny
is six feet tall i just assumed that he
must be
if he's bringing all this stuff how else
would he drag it in the house
um emery says my dad always wanted a son
and ended up with two daughters he'd
jokingly call us little men and he tried
to uh
get get us into things he understood
fishing hunting motorcycles etc
granted i was a total tomboy as a child
but still it's mind-boggling to me that
parents actually try to change their
kids identities because they aren't
happy with the sex
they were created as yeah mind boggling
it is
what it is for parents there is a
diagnosis for it in fact
even though these parents will never be
diagnosed with this now
but this is uh munchausen by proxy
that's what this is
um and munch house of my products when
parents usually it's a mother
and oftentimes with the trans kids you
find that it's a mother especially when
it's a boy becoming a girl
oftentimes coincidentally you find that
there's a mother a mother
very very involved in this process um
and uh with munchausen my proxy it's
oftentimes a mother who
makes her child believe that he is sick
she fabricates sickness for the child
and sometimes causes the child to be
sick
by poisoning a child or something and
she does this number one because she's
mentally ill and number two because it's
attention for her
and sympathy for her the trans child
phenomenon
is that it is a is munch housing by
proxy only it has been normalized
and uh romanticized and now we supposed
to we're supposed to accept it
um finally
let's see uh gerard says i consider matt
an authority on pull-ups
the understanding of momentum and
formicide just look at those guns
wanting to pop out of that non-polka dot
shirt well
gerard i'm gonna let the polka dot come
outside for the time being and the fact
that you're
a guy talking about things popping out
of my shirt uh i'm a little disturbed by
that
i don't know if i'm the authority on um
pull-ups but but
just in the sense that i know how to do
them properly and and
i mean generally if you're doing muscle
building exercises
if you want to build muscle mass there
shouldn't really be momentum in your
exercises because
it's all about form and control that's
what the muscle building exercises are
a lot of guys i see at the gym are
they're going way too fast they don't
have enough control over their movement
uh they're using weight more weight than
they can handle because
you know because it looks better to use
the heavier weights
the other great thing about doing the
exercises properly
is that um because the other thing you
see at the gym is you see people on the
ab machines and all like
all kinds of different ab things people
are doing all of that is
unnecessary because number one if you've
got gut if you've got
fat on your gut you can do all the ab
exercises in the world it's not going to
really do anything about that
gut fat because you've got to diet you
do a lot of cardio for that but number
two
if you're doing muscle building
exercises correctly with the proper form
and your core is engaged
and tight then every exercise is a is an
ab exercise too
so that's a tip a little fitness tip
i hear from businesses all the time uh
that it's it's
it's always tough to find the right
people to fill the positions
that you have open but it's it's only
getting harder you know it's just it's
harder and harder
if you're a business owner who's hiring
you'll probably face a lot of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack
sure you can post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is sit
around and hope that it finds the right
person
no reason to do that this is why you
need ziprecruiter uh you can do that for
free at ziprecruiter.comwalsh when you
post a job on zip recruiter
it gets sent out to over 100 top job
sites with one click then zip recruiters
matching technology
actively finds the people with the right
skill set and experience for your job
and invites them to apply so it's not
sitting there in cyberspace hoping
someone stumbles upon it
they're gonna go and find those people
in fact zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day
you can't argue with success like that
you you simply can't so while other
companies overwhelm you with way too
many options zip recruiter finds
you what you're looking for it's that
simple the needle and the haystack and
right now you could try zip recruiter
for free at this web address
ziprecruiter.com walsh once again
remember to go to this unique place
ziprecruiter.com walsh
recruiter the smartest way to hire now
as we
return from eastern passover it's
important to reflect on the impact
that these holidays have on our faith
and the impact that judeo-christian
values have on our culture more and more
the left wants to erase these values and
replace them with their own
pseudo-morality and that's why we've
launched a brand new talk show
with candace owens one of the fiercest
protectors of conservative values and
free speech
you can go behind the headlines and
twitter fights to see candace as herself
funny political and insightful watch or
host lively discussion
panels and exclusive interviews with
always exciting uh guests
such as myself candace is also the first
daily wire show to appear in front of a
live studio audience which is really
exciting
an element that's rarely been seen in
conservative media at all and that's
that's a whole new thing we're doing a
lot of new things with candace's show
so if you need some candace owens in
your podcast feed look no further head
over to apple podcast
or spotify and subscribe today and be
sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
today we're going to be canceling the
cdc the cdc is by far
my most canceled government agency it
provides me with so many reasons to
cancel it so often that sometimes
the most pertinent cancellation
opportunities get lost in the shuffle so
here's one from last week that i missed
reading the article from cnbc it says
the senators the centers for disease
control and prevention have extended the
national ban on evictions
through the end of june uh quote the
covet 19 pandemic has presented a
historic threat to the nation's public
health
this according to the cdc director dr
rochelle wallensky
keeping people in their homes and out of
crowded or congregated settings like
homeless shelters
by preventing evictions is a key step in
helping to stop the spread of kova 19.
the eviction ban was scheduled to expire
in two days and advocates warned of a
spike in evictions without an extension
around 20 percent of adult renters said
they didn't pay last month's rent
according to a survey published in march
by the census bureau closer to 33 of
black renters
reported the same now as to that last
line i must ask
uh so why do you need to tell us the
statistic for black renters specifically
are you also going to tell us that the
percentage for asian renters
french american renters renters of
pacific island descent and so on
no of course not but still for whatever
reason we need that specific information
on black renters
in any case more to the point here how
in god's holy name
does the cdc have the power to issue a
ban on evictions
from where do they derive that authority
the cdc last i checked as the center for
disease control
do they become the center for disease
control and housing at some point
recently and i missed it
did cdc and hud morph into some kind of
federal megazord and we weren't informed
no the cdc is still the cdc and yet
they've claimed this authority for
themselves
without any concern for the legality of
it
as for the legality question multiple
federal judges have ruled that
no they don't have this power abc news
says this
quote u.s district judge philip
calabrese
sitting in cleveland ruled wednesday
that the cdc went beyond what the
federal public health service act allows
it to do in ordering a halt on evictions
okay but wait for the kicker here
because it continues
however he did not grant an injunction
injunction that would have stopped the
agency from enforcing the moratorium
yes the federal judges are ruling that
this is not constitutional because they
have no choice but to rule that way
because even they lack the legal
creativity to conjure this
constitutional authority
out of thin air yet they still aren't
willing to do anything about it
instead they're standing off at a
distance and symbolically shaking their
fists
ah blasted cdc i disapprove of this
disapprove i say i guess when you shake
your physics more like this right yeah
there we go
um it's all an act of course the the
federal
government has no interest in curbing
its own power
many federal agencies along with
governmental institutions at the state
and local levels have used covid as an
opportunity
to claim unprecedented power for
themselves
they've been like sugar mad children at
a birthday party clawing over each other
to grab the candy that fell out of the
pinata
the candy the treat in this case is
power and government agencies have been
in a mosh pit brawl
fighting with each other to scoop scoop
up every little bit of it that they can
the cdc i think has played this game
perhaps better than any of the rest of
them and this is how
it found it finds itself now waving its
royal scepter and decreeing that
landlords may not evict tenants
even if those tenants refuse to pay
their rent
now um we should not let the question of
authority obscure the perhaps
more important point or at least as
important point
this is also a really terrible idea on
the merits
no matter who is enforcing this
landlords contrary to popular belief
are not all a bunch of scrooge mcducks
swimming in their vats of gold coins to
be a landlord
you only need the capital to make a down
payment on a property that's all you
need you don't need to be a millionaire
for that
the whole point of renting out the
property is that the renters the renters
will pay
or significantly help with the rest of
the expenses
and there are many expenses to include
the obvious stuff like mortgage and
utilities
if renters are not paying their fair
share then landlords who again are for
the most part not wealthy fat cats
they have to reach into their own
pockets now they're bankrupting
themselves so that someone else can live
for free
now yes that other person may be
struggling because of cobit but
so is the landlord so so one struggling
guy
gets to live for free the other has to
pay for himself
and the other guy where's the justice in
that
like they're remember there are two
struggling guys here
so we you you choose to help one at the
expense of the other
never mind the fact that only a certain
portion of renters actually did lose the
ability to pay their rent because of
covet
we seem to have forgotten this in
general
that not everyone lost income during a
lot of people did
not everyone in fact most people didn't
the employment the unemployment rate got
really high but it never got anywhere
near
above 50 percent so the vast majority of
people
are basically in the same financial
situation now that they were a year ago
the majority still have a job didn't
lose any significant income last year
the the eviction moratorium excuses even
employed renters with plenty of money in
the bank
from paying their bills it puts all that
extra burden on the landlord for
literally no reason
the eviction ban could have at least
said that unemployed
renters are excused but instead it
excuses
everyone again for no reason
for the majority of renters there is no
reason why they can't
or shouldn't pay their rent
then what happens when the landlords can
no longer afford the properties that the
renters are living in
well they go bankrupt and then they lose
those properties what happens then
in many cases the bank takes over yeah
yeah
the the little guy really benefits here
if by the little guy we mean the banks
in the long run the effect is that there
will be fewer landlords renting out
fewer properties
which means fewer living options for
people who cannot afford to buy or don't
want to buy
this while even more power and wealth is
transferred to the banks
and that's what the lockdowns have
really wrought and that's why the
lockdowns were really put in place in
the first place so that the wealthy and
powerful could become
more wealthy and more powerful and i
don't mean landlords when i say wealthy
and powerful i mean banks
government agencies the cdc
they make out literally like bandits
but as we covered at the beginning the
left is on the side of the wealthy and
powerful so it's no surprise to see them
cheering along again in this case
and that is why once again and i hope it
sticks this time but
i have my doubts the cdc is canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel valdoski
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. a canadian pastor teaches
americans a thing or two about freedom
and religion mlb gets woke ur
and charles barkley sees what's really
going on in race relations check it out
on the michael knowles show